[Music]
there are things that tell you you've
made it in the big bad world of Show
Business yes millions in the bank a
mountain a white powder groupies and a
HIIT piece from a magazine people no
longer care about there's a lot of
people who won't get that joke most
Millennials have no idea what a magazine
is mate Millennials don't watch our
Channel they're too busy sitting at home
dying their hair and trying to figure
out what gender they
are
the
two anyway a magazine called private eye
has written a hit piece on us with a
circulation of
230,000 people it's one of the
bestselling print magazines then again
being one of the bestselling print
magazines is like being the most liberal
member of Hamas not a high bar it wasn't
all negative they did compare us to The
Beatles which is accurate because like
the Beatles trigonometry is also run by
a Jew their Central argument in
criticizing us is
devastating we host long form
[Music]
podcasts is that it no they also said we
lob softball questions at Fringe weirdos
never thought I'd hear anyone called Jay
Leno Bill Mah Richard Dawkins and Jordan
Peterson Fringe weirdos so they're
jealous of our guests and we do long
form interviews that's their criticism
they're correct we should be like the
mainstream media and do short form
interviews where we can continually
misrepresent and interrupt our guests
I'd rather watch a [__] strung out on
fenel singing Billy Jean than that to be
honest mate that sounds better than
99.9% of all the content online they
also accused us of standing up for the
right to do comedian Bernard Manning's
old material if I had a choice between
Bernard Manning's old material and
private eyes new material I know which
one I'd pick say what you like about
burned but if you dug him up took his
skeleton and propped it up in the
studios of have I got news for you he'd
be the funnyest one there at least he
wouldn't be banging on about brexit the
whole time I mean I think it's fair to
say Bernard Manning would have been Pro
brexit May anyway private I also made
some shocking revelations about my
private life according to them I take
the bins out when my wife asked me to
this is serious you joke but it is
serious Israeli Rockets are far quieter
than a woman who's been ignored on bin
day plus the sound of a rocket exploding
doesn't last for weeks and the
collateral damage is just as great
Rubble everywhere and the neighbors are
up in arms the article also says that we
want to go to America as that's where
all the real Nutters are people love to
hate on America but you have to admit
that everything over there is just at a
high level American Nutters are the best
Nutters and by the best Nutters we
obviously mean those who've received 12
Co Jabs wear six masks and scream at
anyone who goes near them and have more
fat on them than a pork scratching these
are obviously our people can't wait to
sell them trigonometry face visor
pronoun Badges and this is my
4,233 booster sticker and maybe if
they're especially nuts a copy of
private eye he's joking even the
Americans aren't that mental but that
wasn't the only attack from a mainstream
media publication on trigonometry this
week the new Statesmen have placed me at
number 46 on the right power list
whatever that is sounds too much like
white power lless for my liking that's a
smear I've seen you in the gym there's
no power there at all at least they
spell my name correctly unlike yours
that's a good point still your full
place is above list trust and with good
reason I would be an incredible leader
of the conservative party because just
like them I'm not actually conservative
thank you to our partners give send go
for sponsoring this video if you need to
raise funds online but don't want to
hand over your money to faces big Tech
corporations then give s go is a place
to do it on giv send go you can raise
money for whatever you need for free
whether you're in the US the UK
Australia or Canada you can raise funds
for anything from business ventures and
medical expenses to personal needs
churches and funeral costs on giv and go
you can raise money for whatever you
need we've met the people at giv and go
and we can tell you that they're
absolutely aligned with us here at
trigonometry on our approach to free
speech they've proved time and again
that they won't cave to the Mob and
that's why we're proud to partner with
them they don't just talk the talk they
walk the walk unlike other big tech
companies giveen go is absolutely free
to use with other crowdfunding sites
you'll pay between 5 to 10% of the money
you raise give send go charges no money
at all to use their platform they
believe you should be able to keep all
the money you raise starting a campaign
on gend go is easy and intuitive go to
gend go.com today that's gend go.com to
start raising money for whatever is
important to you oh and while we've got
you if you like this then definitely
check out francis's Hal Hal Hal his
Halal taked down w
h [__] me mate we all know what we meant
and then he did her up the ass [__]
me oh and while we've got you if you
like this and definitely check out
francis's hilarious takedown of woke
Hollywood check it out
[Music]
here